[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عنا يعني اقتراحات كلها عندها امكانيه
كلنا بنحب انه نعمل شي ونقدم شيء لكن
المساله بالنهايه ليست مرهونه فينا نحنا
يعني ليست مرهونه بالشعوب العربيه
ليس لها صوت في بلدانها فكيف يمكن لها ان
تضع سياسات ان تساعد يعني الاخرين
[موسيقى]
يبدو انه هوايا الاول لا زمني حتى عندما
اصبحت ممثلا الا تكون امام الا اكون امام
الكاميرا حاولت الكتابه الى فتره يعني
طويله كتبت بعض الافلام التلفزيونيه بعض
المسلسلات بعض قصص قصيره الى سيناريوهات
لكنني اكتشفت فجاه انه مهنه الكتابه هي
مهنه تابعه
[موسيقى]
بطبيعه الحال عندما اقبل على اي عمل فني
فنتحول الى الشريك اساسي فيه وانا اعتقد
انه يعني ما يصنع يعني مسيره اي مخرج ليس
فقط تلك الاعمال التي يقبل باخراجها وانما
تلك الاعمال التي يستطيع ان يقول لها لا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]